donc monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir ce
soir donc olivier dussopt pts ministre
délégué auprès du ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la relance charger
les comptes publics pour une audition
sur le programme de stabilité pour les
années 2000 21 à 2027
nous regrettons malgré tout qu'une
nouvelle fois une contraintes d'agenda
est empêcher monsieur bruno le maire de
7 mai au sénat
après qu'il l'ait fait à l'assemblée
nationale cet après midi même
mais nous savons compter sur votre
disponibilité
monsieur le ministre olivier du sorte
comme vous le savez en application de
l'article 14 de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques 2011 2014
le gouvernement doit adresser au
parlement au moins deux semaines avant
sa transmission à la commission
européenne
je répète au moins deux semaines avant
sa transmission à la commission
européenne le projet de programme de
stabilité
si cette année ses principaux éléments
ont d'abord été communiquée à la presse
jeudi dernier le programme de stabilité
n'a été présenté en conseil des
ministres que ce matin même et
communiqué aux parlementaires à l'heure
du déjeuner on est disponible à l'heure
du déjeuner et pas de problème
ce qui ne permettait pas de préparer et
d'organiser dans de bonnes conditions
d'un débat en séance publique
aussi cette réunion de commission
retransmise en direct s'y substituent
tél elle est ouverte à tous les
sénateurs dans cette salle ou par
visioconférence
c'est à dire ceux de la commission des
finances mais pas quand je les remercie
de leur présence en ligne ou ici l'an
passé le programme de stabilité présenté
en pleine crise sanitaire n'était pas
vraiment il se limitait pour l'essentiel
et à juste titre aux années 2020 et 2021
et se concentrer sur la réponse à donner
à la crise selon les lignes directrices
de la commission européenne
cette année il est l'année le tout
autrement puisqu'il porte sur une
période de huit années nous amenons
jusqu'en 2027
vous nous présenterait donc les
principales hypothèses qu'il comporte et
des moyens dont vous comptez pour
atteindre que vous comptez pour
atteindre les objectifs que vous fixé au
delà de ce programme de stabilité
vous nous indiquer comment le
gouvernement entend informer le
parlement avant sa transmission à la
commission européenne du plan national
pour la reprise et la résilience qu'on
appelle pnrr qui doit détailler la
stratégie d'investissement et de réforme
en france qui conditionne les versements
au titre du plan de relance européen
contrairement à d'autres pays qui ont
déjà mis en ligne des projets de pnrr
voir ouvrir des consultations publiques
en associant leurs parlements nationaux
la france semble faire preuve d'une
grande discrétion sur ce sujet et nous
serions heureux monsieur le ministre que
le parlement puisse être sinon consulter
toutes ont informé sur ce plein air air
avant de donner la parole au ministre je
vous indique que celui-ci aura une
contrainte horaire à 20h15 ce qui nous
donne un plafond aussi après avoir donné
la parole comme il est de tradition au
rapporteur général et au rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales qui est en ligne
je prendrai les questions que vous aurez
bien voulu faire connaître au
secrétariat de la commission pendant
l'exposé du ministre je vous laisse la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs quelques mois d'abord pour
vous remercier d'avoir pu organiser
cette audition en commission dans un
format élargi comme vous l'avez dit avec
une double occasion même si l'essentiel
de nos échanges je crois à vocation à
porter sur le programme de stabilité
double occasion car ce matin en conseil
des ministres nous avons aussi présenté
le projet de loi de règlement
quinze jours plus tôt que l'année
dernière et quinze jours plus tôt que ce
qui se faisait traditionnellement c'est
une volonté que nous avions annoncé que
de faire coïncider le passage en conseil
des ministres à la fois du programme de
stabilité et du projet de loi de
règlement pour que au delà des dates
d'examen de ce second texte le parlement
puisse être saisie informé à la fois de
l'état constaté des comptes années
précédentes et des prévisions pour les
années à venir permettant ainsi d'avoir
certainement un débat plus riches
puisque éclairé par le résultat d'un
exercice récent ce projet de loi de
règlement très rapidement marc et vient
constater la conséquence des réponses
que nous avons apportées à la crise
sanitaire
sur le plan des finances publiques et
singulièrement sur le plan des finances
de l'état avec un déficit budgétaire qui
passe de 93 milliards an et les fit 2020
à 178 milliards en résultats a constaté
c'est moins dégradée que ce que nous
avions imaginé puisque nous pensions
nous craignons plus exactement avoir un
déficit budgétaire de 223 milliards et
il y à 45 milliards de moindre déficit
mais cela reste un déficit tout à fait
historique est tout à fait abyssal
cet écart à la prévision s'explique à la
fois par une diminution des recettes
fiscales perçues par l'état à hauteur de
37 milliards sont
et par 44,1 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires par rapport à l
alfi 2020 pour l'essentiel porté par la
mission urgence et pour une part porté
par les budgets dit ordinaire de l'état
même si ces dépenses supplémentaires par
rapport à la norme sont pour l'immense
majorité d'entre elles des dépenses
justifiées par la crise je pense par
exemple à l'évolution à la hausse des
appels du fait de la dégradation de la
situation de certains ménages
je pense au versement de deux milliards
cent de primes aux ménages les plus
défavorisés avant l'été et lors du mois
de novembre ou encore à l'achat de
masques et de matériel de protection
pour 800 millions d'euros
mais je pourrais détails et si c'était
nécessaire cet écart se justifie donc
essentiellement par des mesures prises
au titre de la réponse à la crise avec
en particulier 17,8 milliards d'euros de
dépenses liées à l'activité partielle
11,8 pour le fonds de solidarité 3,9
pour les exonérations de cotisations
compenser la sécurité sociale et enfin
8,3 dans le cadre des participations de
l'état soit au capital soit à des
opérations de prêts de long terme à des
entreprises considérées comme
stratégiques comme air france ou encore
la sncf et edf
ce déficit budgétaire donc déficit de
l'état dégradé explique en grande partie
l'évolution du déficit public puisque
nous avons rendu ces chiffres publics
plus exactement l'insee a rendu ces
chiffres publics le déficit public est
passé de 2 2 dans la prévision dont vous
aviez eu à connaître lors de l'examen de
la loi de finances pour 2021 à 9,2 pour
sont à la fois sous l'effet de la
dégradation de la situation budgétaire
l'état sous l'effet de la dégradation
des comptes de la sécurité sociale dont
le déficit a atteint 38,6 milliards
d'euros contre un peu moins de 6 au
moment du vote des lois de finances de
l'état et la sécurité sociale
c'est avec cette situation des finances
publiques que nous avons construit le
programme de stabilité que nous vous
présentons nous avons plusieurs
convictions qui expliquent le programme
que nous vous présentons la première
conviction qu' un des enjeux majeurs en
terme de redressement des finances
publiques et de pouvoir maîtriser le
poids de la dette par
europe au produit intérieur brut c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous nous sommes
fixés comme horizon leur tour un niveau
de déficit proche de 3%
non pas par fétichisme pour par pure
référence un indicateur communautaire
dont nous savons que ils feront l'objet
de débats dans les mois qui viennent
dont nous savons aussi que les
conséquences d'un non respect de ces
critères ne déclenche pas de procédure
particulière puisque la commission a
suspendu l'application des clauses
certaines clauses des traités mais parce
que nous savons que lorsque le déficit
public dans les conditions de croissance
et de l'inflation nous prévoyons atteint
3% ou auto 3%
c'est le point d'inflexion qui permet de
diminuer le poids de la dette par
rapport au pib est donc nous avons fait
le choix de vous proposer une
trajectoire de retour à ce niveau de
déficit qu'ils soient une trajectoire
avec un point d'arrivée en 2027
nous avons considéré que l'hypothèse qui
nous étaient parfois présentés d'un
retour aux alentours 3 % en 2025 était
une hypothèse qui n'étaient pas
suffisamment réalistes qui aurait amené
les efforts par trop important nous
avons aussi considéré que l'hypothèse
proposée par d'autres d'un retour à 3 %
en 2030 était une hypothèse trop
lointaine avec un risque de décrochage
de notre pays en termes d' équilibre de
situation des comptes publics par
rapport à nos partenaires européens et
des risques notamment sur l'évolution
des taux n'est pas seulement sur notre
capacité et la crédibilité que ray a
gardé notre économie sur la scène
européenne et sur la scène mondiale
pour atteindre cet objectif de 3% de
déficit en 2027
cela signifie que la dépense en volume
dépenses publiques en volume devrait
être limité dans son augmentation à +0
7% par an c'est un effort qui est assez
important qui mérite d'être comparés
nous avons une évolution de la dépense
en volume qui en moyenne est de 0,6 à
0,7 pour cent sur les années 2018 2019
nous avons connues collectivement une
évolution de la dépense en volume autour
de 1% entre 2012 et 2017
c'était 1,2 pour cent de 2002 de 2007 à
et c'était 2 1% lors du quinquennat de
2 à 2007 c'est donc un effort qui devra
être fait pour non pas diminuer la
dépense publique mais faire en sorte
qu'elle augmente moins vite que la
croissance et l'inflation et que cette
augmentation soit limitée à 0,7 pour
cent au delà de la perspective d'un
retour autour de 3% en 2027
ses trajectoires présente à nos yeux
d'autres avantages le premier avantage
est que avec ses trajectoires nous
retrouvons à horizon 2025 2027 un poids
de la dépense publique à peu près
comparable à celui que nous avons hâte
en 2019 c'est-à-dire 53,8 pour cent en
baisse d'un point et demi par rapport au
début du quinquennat
nous retrouvons un niveau de
prélèvements obligatoires par rapport au
pibe plus rapidement autour de 3,2 43.7
43.8 que nous avions atteint aussi en
2019 avec une baisse d'un peu plus d'un
point du poids des prélèvements
obligatoires par rapport au pibe lors
des trois années les trois premières
années du quinquennat
c'est aussi cette trajectoire qui nous
permet de stabiliser la dette autour de
117 118 % jusqu'en 2026 2027 avant de
connaître une inflexion et une
diminution légère certes mais une
diminution du poids de la dette par
rapport aux pieds je précise par
ailleurs comme lorsque nous disons qu'il
nous faudra limiter la progression de la
dépense publique à 0 27 % par an c'est
évidemment hors dépenses d'urgence que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui au titre
des missions d'une mission urgence et
hors relance puisque nous raisonnons sur
le périmètre des dépenses que je
qualifie parfois d'ordinaire même si le
terme n'a pas de portée juridique pour
mais simplement pour les isolés par
rapport aux missions urgences et aux
missions relance que le parlement a créé
à l'occasion de l'adoption des plfr et
et des pelles je ne vais pas être
beaucoup plus long monsieur le président
je rajouterais simplement que la
trajectoire que nous vous proposons
s'appuie sur un certain nombre
d'hypothèses
certaines relèvent de choix politiques
d'autres sont des hypothèses
conventionnel parmi les hypothèses de
choix politique que nous avons retenu il
n'y a pas d'augmentation des
prélèvements obligatoires tels que nous
l'avons toujours affirmé depuis le début
de cette crise et nous avons même
intégré la poursuite de la diminution de
certains prélèvements jusqu'à la fin
2022 comme nous nous y étions engagés
les hypothèses plus conventionnel
concerne le taux d'inflation concerne le
taux de croissance j'en dirai un mot et
les taux d'intérêt sur la question du
taux de croissance nous prévoyons une
croissance à hauteur de 5% c'est-à-dire
légèrement revu à la baisse en deux par
rapport à nos hypothèses en 2021
puisque nous prévoyons 6% mais que la
prise en compte des contraintes que nous
connaissons nous a amené à la ramener à
5% de 4% 2022 et ensuite un retour
progressif au tour de 1,4 soit très
légèrement supérieur à l'hypothèse de
croissance classique mais il ya là les
effets à la fois de la reprise et du
plan de relance
pour ce qui concerne les taux d'intérêt
nous sommes assez convaincus de
l'hypothèse de stabilité relative des
taux d'intérêt même si les tensions
inflationnistes que nous connaissons les
ramène plus tôt dans des eaux positives
plutôt que dans les eaux négative
cependant dans le cas de la construction
du p stade nous avons retenu les
hypothèses les plus conventionnels c'est
à dire un retour à des taux positifs
tels que vous pouvez le constater dans
les documents qui vous ont été transmis
et donc nous avons intégrée à l'horizon
2027 une augmentation du poids de la
charge de la dette d'un demi point
passant de 1,3 à 1,8 pour cent du pib
je pense et j'espère que cette
augmentation ne sera pas constaté mais
la volatilité des taux nous oblige de
cette prudence et intégrer cette
hypothèse dans celle que nous vous
présentons pour comme sous pour
expliquer les choix et la trajectoire du
pays stable que nous vous présentons
voilà monsieur le président ce que je
peux dire en introduction pour laisser
je l'espère plus de place aux questions
et répondre certainement plus
précisément sur certains items aux
questions des sénateurs
merci monsieur le ministre dans le même
esprit je vais pour l'instant conservé
les questions que j'avais prévu de de
vous poser et s'ils ne sont pas évoqués
par mes collègues je les rajouterai
enfin deux enfin de questionnements je
vais donner la parole tout de suite au
rapporteur général en indiquant
simplement que compte tenu de la
présentation ce jour du programme de
stabilité et de la prochaine suspension
parlementaire le rapporteur général vous
adressera pendant la la suspension
parlementaire son analyse sur ce
programme de stabilité je veux dire
analyse complète en tant que rapporteur
général est que cette analyse donnera
lieu à un échange en commission le
mercredi 5 mai prochain sera porte en
général
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
d'abord pour confirmer mes sioniste mes
chers collègues que je partage les
propos en tout point introductif du
président claude raynal vous remercier
monsieur le ministre d'avoir d'abord
d'être toujours disponibles et pour
cette présentation synthétique et je me
contenter dans un premier temps n'ont
pas de nom pas un début d'analysé mais à
vous adresser
3 questions pour permettre que le temps
des changes au sein de la commission
puisse avec nos collègues des affaires
sociales puissent être mises à profit
tout d'abord monsieur le ministre
deux rapports à de la commission arthuis
un autre duo conseil du financement de
la protection sociale se sont prononcés
pour n'est que la dette qu'ovide ne soit
pas cantonné pourtant dans le programme
de stabilité
le gouvernement confirme au contraire le
choix du cantonnement
pouvez-vous à cesta de monsieur le
ministre nous faire part de ce que
j'appellerais une forme d'entêtement
alors que l'identification simple de la
dette co-lead eu pu suffire
deuxième question vous prévoyez
également un redressement rapide vous
l'avez évoqué des finances publiques au
cours du quinquennat qui s'ouvrira d'ici
à 2027
ce qui d'après nos calculs supposerait
un montant d'économies de l'ordre de 60
milliards d'euros sur la période hors de
ce qui figure dans le document
or une réforme des retraites peut et 10
sur les voies et moyens de cette
maîtrise de la dépense
permettez-moi donc d'exprimer quelques
doutes j'ai en tête notamment les
engagements qui avaient été pris pour
réduire la dépense publique à travers
cinquante mille suppressions d'emplois
publics
promise qui finalement sont restées
lettre morte
question monsieur le ministre ou pensez
vous pouvez trouver ces économies
puisque finalement 2023 va arriver bien
vite
enfin dans une étude rexecode qui est
paru hier indique un scénario de du
programme de stabilité qui conduirait en
fait à dépasser nos objectifs
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'ordre de 28 millions de tonnes de co2
d'ici à 2030 pour résorber un tel écart
il faudrait en fait augmenter les
investissements de la france et
investissements verts de l'ordre de 12
milliards d'euros par an d'ici à 2030 ce
qui montre bien le lien entre une dette
publique est ce que j'appelle mais je
suis pas tout seul la dette climatique
le programme de stabilité étant tout à
fait muet sur le sujet pouvez vous donc
nous apporter des éclaircissements sur
cette ambition à laquelle il faudra bien
monsieur mise que la france réponde
merci monsieur l'a pourtant général
avant que vous répondriez rapporteur
général je vous propose d'écouter jean
marie vanlerenberghe rapporteur général
de la commission des affaires sociales
et vous répondrez aux deux rapporteurs
généraux jean marie tu
oui vous m'entendez parfaitement bon
écoutez merci je vous remercie monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre et
monsieur le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances ainsi que
monsieur le président de la commission
aux affaires européennes je suis très
heureux effectivement de pouvoir
observant effectivement vos
recommandations sur président est allé à
l'essentiel
en ce qui concerne notamment les
projections relatives aux
administrations de sécurité sociale d
assaut tout d'abord le programme du
gouvernement montrent une trajet une
trajectoire financière d assaut qui
appelle trou d'air des années dans la 21
revient progressivement à l'équilibré
dans pour retrouver son rythme de
croisière à l'horizon 2025 les assauts
serait alors annexée
dans dans un excédent de 0 7 point de pi
correspondant recettes de la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale la
cades est ce cette révision me
conduisent tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre à vous demander si cette
trajectoire est compatible avec
l'absorption par la cad s des déficits
cumulés qui ont été prévues par la loi
notamment que de la dette sociale et de
toner en d'autres termes le
remboursement de cette dette sociale à
la fin 2030 toit reste t'il une
perspective crédible
pourriez vous aussi de plus
pardon de plus vous demander monsieur
ministre à travers effectivement le
rapport que vous nous avez remis coup
demandé aux assauts je cite de
participer à la modération des dépenses
alors que nous savons parfaitement
qu'avec le ségur de la santé la future
loi et autonomie et dépendance que l'on
peut espérer
celles ci vont augmenter
significativement
pourriez-vous donc nous préciser comment
orcades s les autres secteurs d aso
pourrait être à l'équilibré dès 2025
alors que la dernière loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale prévoyaient un
déficit de 8 24 de plus de grain
milliards d'euros sur le périmètre des
as ou s'agissant d'exercice 2021
le programme de stabilité prévoit d'ores
et déjà un dérapage spectaculaire de
dépenses de crise de l'assurance maladie
plus 13 milliards 4 par rapport à 2020
au lieu des 4 milliard 3 prévue en loi
de financement en 2021
pourriez vous détailler les postes de
dépenses qui conduisent à ce glissement
de quelques 9 milliards en quatre mois
d'autre part et voyez-vous de dispose de
déposer un projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale en
une question récurrente depuis l'année
dernière la commission des affaires
sociales considère pour sa part que les
dépenses arbitral
même financé par la sécurité sociale
devrait présenter un caractère limitatif
et puis s'agissant de la dette qu vide
j'ai noté que le programme de stabilité
propose l isoler à hauteur de 140
milliards d'euros afin de pouvoir
retracer son remboursement
la dette covit de l'état bien sûr une
telle approche vous semble-t-elle
compatible avec le traitement de la
dette de la sécurité sociale qui
comprend aussi une part exceptionnelles
liées à la réponse sanitaire et même
aussi à la réponse économique au travers
des baisses de recettes due à l'activité
partielle
en d'autres termes sur le ministre est
il logique est optimal de rembourser
cette fraction de dettes en 12 ans au
regard de la norme que s'applique l'état
et enfin pour conclure de manière plus
institutionnelle
la proposition de loi organique que j'ai
récemment déposé avec la présidente de
roche et le président guidon ainsi que
président de l'amex et les rapporteurs
de notre commission propose notamment de
faire coïncider le périmètre des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
celui des assauts notamment pour
faciliter le suivi de la trajectoire
voté par le programme des finances
publiques qui est présenté aujourd'hui
le gouvernement soutient-il une telle
évolution
voilà monsieur le ministre mes questions
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci jean marie monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez répondre à ses premières
questions merci monsieur le président je
vais essayer de répondre en précisant
monsieur le président que je n'ai pas
répondu à votre interpellation sur le
programme national de résilience que
vous aviez évoqué dans votre propos
liminaire que le gouvernement qui doit
transmettre ce programme normalement fin
avril avant la fin avril
évidemment la disposition du parlement
pour l'évoquer il s'agit d'une position
d'un positionnement gouvernementale mais
on gagne toujours à échanger sur le
sujet de la même manière nous
transmettrons à la toute fin du mois
d'avril le paix stable c'est-à-dire dans
les quinze jours qui suivent sa
transmission et d'information du
parlement pour ce qui confirmait des
trois questions posées par monsieur
rapporteur général
de la commission des finances un premier
point sur cette question du cantonnement
ou d'isolement nous avons proposé au
parlement qu'il a voté d'aller plus loin
en matière de cantonnement la dette
sociale avec le texte organique votée
l'été dernier qui transfère à la cades
est comme cela a été dit je reviendrai
les déficits constatés en 2020 mais
aussi jusqu'en 2023 par la sécurité
sociale
nous proposons avec bruno le maire que
pour ce qui concerne la dette de l'état
liées à la crise du coc vide autour de
140 millions de 140 milliards d'euros
nous puissions procéder un peu
différemment
nous disposons d'un outil la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette publique qui
contrairement à la cades s ne nécessite
pas le fléchage devenir ne nécessite pas
de manière organique le fléchage d'une
ressource pérenne et récurrente pour
assurer le financement de
l'amortissement de la dette qui lui est
confiée ce fléchage de ressources peut
être l'objet d'une subvention annuelle
voter un plf et nous proposons que la
dynamique des recettes fiscales liée à
la croissance est donc lié à la reprise
soit mobilisée pour subventionner la
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
publique et ainsi participer à un
cantonnement qui ne serait pas un
cantonnement identique à celui du co
ville mais peut-être plus pour reprendre
la différence des termes que vous avez
évoqué monsieur le rapporteur général un
une forme d'isolement mais avec la
lisibilité que nous recherchons et la
possibilité de flécher des ressources
spécifiques pour amortir cette dette
nous avons fait le choix vous l'avez dit
de retenir une trajectoire de retour
autour de 3%
d'ailleurs nous entendons par toutefois
parler de retour à l'équilibré en est
rien c'est un retour à un déficit de 3%
à l'horizon 2027
nous pouvons considérer avec vous que
c'est un retour rapide nous sommes que
c'est la bonne entente oralité que 2025
aurait été trop rapide et que 2030 nous
paraît trop lointain pour les raisons
que j'ai évoquées dans mon propos
liminaire là où monsieur le rapporteur
général j'ai un désaccord avec vous
c'est quand on quantum d'économies ont
tendance à réaliser pour atteindre cet
objectif
vous avez évoqué le chiffre de 60
milliards d'euros il nous semble que
nous sommes plutôt entre 40 et 45
milliards d'euros
mais ça fait à l'occasion des
discussions sur la manière de documenter
et nous devrons
si à l'occasion notamment des prochaines
lois de finances et votre programmation
pluriannuelle des finances publiques
dont nous avons dit que nous considérons
une au portant de la discuter avant la
fin du quinquennat considérant que ce
serait prendre des engagements trop
tardivement par rapport à l'échéance
présidentielle sera l'occasion de
documenter un signe de réformes
structurelles
je ne reviens pas pour sur celles qui
sont le plus souvent évoqué mais il ya
d'autres réformes parfois plus technique
mais qui permettent aussi de dégager un
certain nombre d'économies nous
travaillons actuellement sur la
réorganisation et la rénovation du plan
des achats de l'état avec un objectif
d'économies à trois ans à hauteur de 800
millions d'euros 1 milliard d'entre eux
800 et 1 milliard 800 millions pardonnez
moi et un milliard d'euros
réformes beaucoup plus discrète que la
réforme des retraites qui est souvent
évoqué mais qui génère aussi des
économies que nous allons pouvoir
mobiliser et il n'est pas prévu à
l'occasion du programme de stabilité de
tracer un programme d'investissement et
nous tracer un programme
d'investissement et compris fléchés vers
la décarbonation le verdissement
j'ai pris connaissance comme vous
monsieur rapporteur de l'étude en
question qui interpelle qui peut trouver
sur une réponse notamment dans le budget
vert avec les moyens qui sont consacrés
à la transition écologique
mais le p stables tels que nous le
présentons tels que nous devons de
présenter n'a pas vocation à intégrer de
telles trajectoires d'investissement et
j'ajoute mais c'est le ministre du
budget qui le dit de manière peut-être
plus singulières encore que les
programmations furet annuels ont aussi
le défaut la rigidification et que la
rigidification est assez peu compatible
avec la recherche de marges de manoeuvre
pour atteindre des objectifs notamment
en matière de désendettement pour
répondre à monsieur le rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales nous nous considérons que
l'objectif qui a été fixé lors de la loi
organique d'apurement de la dette
confiait la cad s est un objectif qui
est au nabeul et nous le considérons
d'autant plus que finalement le déficit
constaté de la sécurité sociale pour le
régime général et arrange les yes a été
un niveau important et même historique
38 milliards 6 mai un peu plus de 10
milliards moins important que ce que
nous craignons lors de l'adoption du
plfss est donc ce moindre déficit mais
je le dis avec précaution dans la mesure
où ça reste
sites historiques nous encourage plutôt
à considérer comme tenable l'objectif
que nous avons fixé il y à un certain
nombre de dépenses qui sont d'ores et
déjà intégré mais si le rapporteur a
parlé du ségur à juste titre avec des
dépenses qui ont pu être réalisés dès
2020 une dépense importante à partir de
1021 c'est évidemment pris en compte
dans le socle auquel s'appliqueront
ensuite la règle s'appliquera ensuite la
règle des 0,7 pour cent en volume
il n'est pas prévu à ce stade et et
c'est un objet de débat assez récurrent
entre les membres de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat et le
gouvernement qu'il soit déposé un projet
de loi de finances rectificatif pour la
sécurité sociale
nous considérons que la norme telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui permet au
gouvernement d'abonder de manière
parfois importantes c'est ce qui a été
fait en 2020 le plfss et les ressources
de la sécurité sociale sans
nécessairement soumettre cet abondement
au parlement pour des questions
essentiellement de calendrier
parlementaire nous n'avons pas prévu
d'inscrire un tel texte et nous mettons
à profit si je puis dire les marges qui
ne sont ainsi donnés je souscris
cependant à l'idée générale est exposée
par monsieur le rapporteur et je pense
que les propositions de loi organique
qui seront prochainement examinée
permettront d'apporter des réponses et
peut-être de créer cette forme
d'obligation à ce stade par me permettez
moi monsieur le rapporteur général de ne
pas me prononcer spécifiquement sur la
ppl organique que vous avez déposé pour
ne pas l'avoir suffisamment étudiée et
parce que je sais aussi que un certain
nombre de députés autour du rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
de l'assemblée vont déposer des textes
concernant le même sujet et qu'il nous
reviendra alors pour le gouvernement
d'avoir un tel positionnement pour ce
qui concerne l'augmentation de la de
l'ondam au cours de l'année 2000 21 jeux
sous serait évidemment aux propos de
monsieur van den berg avec cette
augmentation prévue de 13 4 milliards
d'euros
c'est un écart à la norme 2 9 milliards
qui s'expliquent par un coût plus
important que ce que nous avions imaginé
en pelles fss de la campagne de
vaccination
je rappelle que nous avions inscrit 1
milliards cinq pour la campagne de
vaccination à une époque où nous ne
savions pas encore à quelle date serait
disponible et vaccins dans quelle
quantité et à quel coût
de l'avion inscrit comme une pro vie une
provision en précisant que ça ferait
certainement réévalué par ailleurs le
fait que l'épidémie soit virulente plus
longtemps que ce que nous avions espéré
amène aussi des surcoûts pour le système
de santé qui se traduisent par cette
augmentation par rapport à l'an dames
ainsi prévu voilà ce que je pouvais dire
monsieur le président en réponse à ses
premières séries de questions
merci monsieur le ministre nous allons
maintenant ouvrir donc le débat avec en
rappelant à chacun que le souhait c'est
de rester à deux minutes d'intervention
par question tout temps économisé sera
redonné dans une prochaine commission
donc jean françois rapin pour prod pour
deux minutes
oui j'irai très vite monsieur monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs généraux en
sachant que j'ai trois questions donc si
j'ai bien compris ces six minutes
nous non rassurez-vous je plaisante
monsieur le ministre nous avons eu donc
le programme de stabilité moi je
voudrais savoir comment le programme de
stabilité s'articule et s'il y a des
éléments d'articulation avec le
programme de reprise et de résilience
nous a été proposé par le gouvernement
c'est ma première question la deuxième
concerne plus l'aspect européen et les
40 milliards d'euros de financements
européens qui devrait nous arriver
savoir si eux aussi sont intégrés dans
le dispositif programme de stabilité
et si on a plus de précisions
aujourd'hui sur le la décomposition
parce que je dois dire qu'on reste
encore très très dans le flou sur 7 sur
cette question et puis la dernière
allait aussi très vite vous l'avez
évoqué assez brièvement dans vos deux
propos liminaire parlant du déficit et
des 3% de stabilité on a vu dans un
article du monde qu'une déclaration du
président de la république proposé de
revoir les conditions de
de cette stabilité à 3% pensez vous que
la france soit très double aujourd'hui
au regard de nos finances publiques pour
engager un débat débat un débat de ce
type
merci monsieur le ministre merci jean
françois vincent delahaye et merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
moi je regrette quand même qu' on n'est
pas un débat dans l'hémicycle sur ce
programme de stabilité que l'on doive en
débattre assez rapidement ici en
commission alors qu'on a reçu le
document à 13h et que à 18h45 on nous
demande de débattre c'est quand même un
petit peu compliqué surtout avec la
valse des milliards à laquelle on a
assisté et qui se retrouve un petit peu
dans le document c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu compliqué d'y voir totalement
clair donc moi j'aurai beaucoup
d'observation à faire comme j'ai que
deux minutes et que j'aime bien
respecter les temps de parole je vais me
contenter d'une question que sur les
emprunts garantis par l'état
je sais plus si c'est 100 milliards ou
un peu plus ou un peu moins je sais plus
exactement à combien on en est quel est
le scénario qui a été retenu dans ce
programme de stabilité pour prendre en
compte des abonde créant sur ses
emprunts garantis par l'état et qu'elles
seraient des montants de ces abandons de
créances en tout cas quelles sont les
prévisions ce que j'ai vu qu'il y avait
des critiques quand même de la cour des
comptes sur la sincérité des estimations
faites dans les plaies faire de 2020 par
le gouvernement qui sont quand même
peut-être un petit peu non conformité
sur la sincérité qui était jusque-là un
marqueur de l'action du gouvernement en
matière financière et donc j'aimerais
avoir la stratégie est ce que vous
prévoyez de parce que je vois rien dans
le document du tout sur cet aspect là
merci vincent sophie tellier pour lyon
merci monsieur le président sur
rapporteur général monsieur ministre moi
je je je partage effectivement un
certain nombre d'interrogations qui ont
été portées notamment par le président
reynal sur le plan de relance et de
résilience donc nous attendons d'ici une
quinzaine de jours puisqu'on ravi de le
regarder avec une grande attention je
partage également les interrogations
voire les après des inquiétudes du
rapporteur général sur la question du
respect de nos engagements climatiques
parce que à la lecture non pas du
document bien entendu puisque nous ne la
que depuis quelques heures mais des
articles de presse puisque par contre la
presse a vu écho de ce programme de
stabilité on sen t on est plus que
légitime à s'interroger et à s'inquiéter
sur la capacité de la france à respecter
ses engagements climatiques et sur sa
capacité à financer et bien le simple
respect de ses engagements
ensuite je rejoins totalement la
question sur les 3 % et la présidence
française
c'est vrai que mon étonnement a été
grand quand après la lecture du même
article du monde qui disait que la
présidence française de l'ue une femme
un des objectifs de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
s'étaient de militer pour que cette
règle des 3% puisse être revu très très
profondément et de voir que dans ce
programme de stabilité là c'est cet
objectif même que l'on reprend manque un
petit peu de cohérence en termes de
lisibilité politique
donc évidemment cette question et est
apparaît avec voilà beaucoup de fins
d'étonnement je veux dire on ne comprend
pas après la question que je me pose
évidemment c'est aussi la question de
de ce programme de stabilité comment
comment faire en sorte de ne pas
reconduire les erreurs du passé
c'est à dire de se lancer très vite trop
vite dans une politique qui finalement
est un programme osterrieth r et
d'ailleurs ce que nous craignons à
l'occasion de notamment des projets de
loi de finances rectificative ou
initiaux dans le projet de loi de
relance est à dire le fait d'avoir isolé
les les ce qui concernait la relancer
d'urgence ne permettent finalement de
revenir très vite à une politique
autoritaire et c'est ce qu'on constate
on a isolé tout ça pour pouvoir
continuer business as usual de la baisse
des dépenses publiques et la plupart du
temps évidemment de la baisse des
dépenses publiques qui viennent protéger
les françaises et les français et qui
viennent financer les services publics
donc évidemment ces questions nous nous
interroge plus des recettes +0 7 % de
dépenses en volume et bien où allez vous
coupez assurance chômage bien entendu
c'est certainement ça votre projet alors
allez vous aller encore plus loin
alors que vous n'êtes pas au niveau des
problèmes majeurs que rencontre
tellement de français par rapport à
l'urgence sociale
vous nous annoncer demain des coupes à
nouveau drastiques dans les budgets
sociaux
merci sophy vous aurez une minute de
moins la prochaine fois charles guené
merci monsieur le président simplement
je
j'ai raccourci monde et je n'ai donc
j'ai pu dire un petit peu donc je je me
suis concentré sur ce qui concernait les
collectivités locales et notamment la
page 37 je retrouve à moyen terme
l'association des collectivités locales
retour progressif à l'équilibré des
comptes impliquerait la poursuite des
objectifs de maîtrise des dépenses de
fonctionnement
on pense immédiatement au contrat de
cahors et met cependant comme comme il
s'agit d'une contractualisation un peu d
eau nine
j'ai imaginé qu'on allait trouver autre
chose au paragraphe nouvelle gouvernance
que j'ai effectivement trouvé à la page
70 et puisque nous avons une réforme de
la gouvernance des finances publiques
proposées par le gouvernement et soutenu
par le gouvernement sera présenté pour
traduire des orientations
alors c'est une formulation dont on n'a
pas tout à fait d'habitude alors à moins
que ce soit une nouvelle gouvernance
puisées à bonnes sources
alors pourriez-vous nous à cet égard
nous donner la méthode de et le timing
justement parce que nous préciser la
méthode parce que le parlement je veux
bien kg de la donne mais je pense à une
idée et ensuite nous donnait
effectivement les mécanismes envisagés
merci merci charles rémi féraud puis
michel canevet ne se prête pas merci
monsieur le président pour ne pas
répéter ce qui a été dit et notamment
les interrogations que je partage de
sophie calle polian jeu devrait poser
deux questions d'une part qu'est ce qui
pour vous monsieur le ministre fait que
l'engagement de maîtrise d'augmentation
des dépenses
0 7 % seraient plus crédibles après
qu'avant je sais monsieur darmana
m'avait répondu lors d'une audition dans
un même cadre
et puis s'il ya un an ou deux ans mais
de toute façon pourquoi voulez-vous
réduire les dépenses publiques et le
déficit structurel vous êtes contre mais
en fait c'est pas le sujet c'est la
question c'est quel est le rapport entre
la parole du gouvernement et ses actes
et c'est vrai que si on regarde le
déficit structurel certes avant le
déclenchement de la crise
son niveau était à peu près conforme à
ce qui était dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques je
crois 2% -2 % mais très loin de
l'objectif qui était fixé assez
rapidement suite avant que la crise se
déclenche et il n'y avait pas cette
maîtrise des dépenses publiques qui nous
permettait de voir l'objectif atteint et
d'un autre côté si et je le pense
il ne faut pas se lancer dans une
maîtrise des dépenses publiques même si
vous avez 10 3% de déficit de seulement
2027 parce qu'il ne faut pas aller trop
vite et c est ce que vous pensez pas
qu'en présentant ce programme de
stabilité comme ça maintenant vous êtes
en train de louper un moment politique
qui est celui de la mise en place d'une
nouvelle politique aux etats unis
avec l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires pas pour tous les
contribuables
mais pour les plus riches pour les
grandes entreprises pour les gagnants de
la crise vous nous répondre et vous me
répondrez que nous ne partons pas du
même niveau
mais l'important oui mais nous n'avons
pas non plus le même système de
redistribution et l'important c'est le
chemin c'est la tendance est ce qu'on
n'est pas là avec ce programme de
stabilité qui malheureusement en effet
n'est pas voilà discutée en séance au
parlement mais seulement en audition est
ce qu'on n'est pas en train de louper un
moment politique pour engager d'autres
perspectives et est une vraie relance
merci rémi michel canévet remercie
jérôme bascher merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre chaque
collègue contrairement à mes collègues
qui viennent de s'exprimer à l'instant
je suis plutôt préoccupé par l'évolution
de la dépense publique et
je souhaite qu'après la période où les
dépenses ont fortement crû du fait de la
pandémie qu'après la relance nous
puissions rapidement retrouvé une
maîtrise des dépenses publiques c'est
indiqué dans le document
il aurait été intéressant qu'on est
peut-être plus d'éléments d'informations
sur la manière dont on pourrait il ya et
aboutir il ya bien sûr les réformes sont
évoqués dans le document les réformes la
réforme des retraites et puis une
réforme technique financière notamment
sur les achats vous avez ok monsieur le
ministre mais le document aurait gagné à
être enrichie de quelques autres
orientations en ce sens et en
particulier sur les questions des
dépenses de personnel qui sont des
dépenses récurrentes et sur lesquels il
y a des des coups assez important donc
c'est dommage que le document ne soit
pas plus argumentée sur le sujet et ma
question portait surtout sur les
contrats de chaos évoqué par charles
guené pour autant pour les communes
ça ne pose pas à mon sens de problèmes
sur dans une situation qui est plutôt
pas assez bonnes par contre pour les
départements les contrats de cahors
posent de sérieuses difficultés du fait
du poids des dépenses sociales des
départements et de la situation sociale
dont on peut craindre que une nouvelle
contrainte
des départements sur les dépenses
risquent d'altérer leur capacité à
intervenir et à répondre aux problèmes
sociaux de proximité qui sont
identifiées donc il faut que le
gouvernement soit attentif à cela
merci michel jérôme bascher puis
christine lagarde
merci monsieur le président d'abord qui
peut de macroéconomie je suis un peu
inquiète vos hypothèses d'inflation
monsieur le ministre à rentrer le
déflateur du pib celui la conso des
ménages et le salaire moyen par tête
il n'y a rien de cohérent si ce n'est
qu'il ya pas de chômage dans votre
scénario macroéconomique il n'y a pas de
chômage
donc il n'ya pas de crise économique et
sociale mes chers collègues il n'y a pas
d'hypothèse de chômage dans votre
rapport
et il ya en tout cas pas de chômage qui
explose alors c'est évidemment
totalement orthogonale à ce que dit le
consensus forecast mais c'est pas grave
vous il n'y a pas de chômage
donc je suis peut-être un peu inquiet
sur cette partie là sans doute à tort
cassandre a toujours eu tort sur le
pacte de stabilité et de croissance
j'en ressors apavou l'a parfaitement dit
si on veut enterrer le pacte de
stabilité de croissance et savoir qu'il
faut effectivement il revenir dessus
ce document en est la parfaite
illustration jamais la france jamais n'a
respecté son pacte de stabilité et de
croissance
et là vous faites mieux vous l'illustré
vous illustrez vous n'avez pas le tenir
car avec 0 7% de croissance de la
dépense publique là où en moyenne
annuelle en affaires quatre des dix
dernières années
tout va bien vous allez réussir parce
que notamment les taux d'intérêt vont
continuer à baisser monsieur le ministre
car c'était une d1 des grands facteurs
dead de la baisse de la dépense publique
hélas hélas hélas ça ne marche pas et
l'ondam c'est aussi ce qui sort du ségur
on a entendu tout à leur rapporteur de
la sécurité sociale
ces quatre ennemis moyenne nous faut
quatre ennemis on n'y est pas dans votre
dans votre rapport dont on ne sait pas
où on va faire les économies alors j'en
viendrais à laquelle vous avez parlé de
la caisse de la dette publique
d'amortissement de la dette publique
c'est une bonne idée mais c'est pas un
cantonnement
alors je veux bien croire que vous ayez
retrouver ce vieil établissement ni
d'une trentaine d'années
si je ne m'abuse 25 ans 26 ans peut-être
monsieur ministre il reste 30 ans 30 ans
mais c'est pas un cantonnement
donc je suis un peu surpris que vous
appeliez ça un cantonnement la housse
est affecté des recettes supplémentaires
au moment de rouler la dette et c'est
pas tout à fait un cantonnement
cantonner ses maîtres de la dette c'est
ce que fait la cad s est elle le fait
plus cher donc je suis un peu surpris de
tout vos hypothèses
merci jérôme christine lagarde puis
bernard delcros oui merci alors comme
mes collègues michel cave et eicher
gainey j'ai effectivement la crainte que
la réduction de la dépense soit porté
par les seules collectivités puisque
dans votre propos liminaire comme seul
outil à de réduction vous nous avez cité
un nouveau plan d'achat de l'état c'est
une politique qui semble-t-il n'est pas
nouvelle en tout cas pour le ministère
que je contrôle qui n'est pas le plus
petit on a déjà des indicateurs de suivi
dans les documents qui sont présentés au
parlement sinon j'aurai une seule
question à vous poser
vous avez mis en avant le coût pour
l'état de l'activité partielle j'aurais
aimé savoir si l'état qui est son propre
assureur a chiffré le coût des
fonctionnaires qui étaient en
autorisations spéciales d'absence ou en
haricot vide ou tel autre nature pour
qu'on puisse avoir un pendant entre
l'activité privée et l'activité publique
merci christine pendant que bernard
delcros va s'exprimer nous avons
quelques collègues qui sont en
présentiel d'autres commissions s'ils
souhaitent poser une question bien sûr
nous nous leur donnons la parole qui
veuille bien se manifester en levant la
main
bernard oui merci ce ministre à trois
questions la première porte sur la
dépense publique vous avez affiché un
objectif utile mais ambitieux en même
temps de limiter la progression à 0 7%
par an sur la période
pouvez vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
les leviers sur lesquels vous comptez
agir pour maîtriser cette cette dépense
publique
quelques ailes quels moyens quels
laquelle rem et des ajouts des réformes
d'ailleurs pour cela
deuxième question elle porte sur les
collectivités locales le 0 7% par an
concerne toutes les administrations
publiques et je rejoins un peu la
question de charles guené
vous dire quelles sont vos intentions
concernant les collectivités locales est
ma dernière question pour tous les
prélèvements obligatoires vous avez
engagé depuis pur année une une
politique de diminution des prélèvements
obligatoires pour la taxe d'habitation
cet acte est donc elle ira à son terme
le concernant les impôts de production
donc moins 10 milliards en 2021 il était
prévu moins 10 milliards en 2022
maintenez-vous 7,7 cet objectif là et
sur l'impôt sur les sociétés la baisse
progressive pour la ramener à 25% êtes
vous toujours sur cette ligne a pour
2022 merci je ne vois pas d'autres
demandes précises donc simplement avant
de redonner la parole au ministre je
vais me permettre de compléter par
quelques questionnements moi même
d'abord je ne note pas dans ce rapport
de renforcement des mesures de soutien
et de relance
est-ce que j'ai bien lu rien en
particulier sur les dépenses d'avenir
jeu même le rapport arthuis mettez des
dépenses minimales d'avenir
d'investissements d'avenir
c'était pas énorme mais là il n'y a même
pas de référence à ce point et
finalement vous constatez plutôt une
perte de richesse annuelle de l'ordre de
60 milliards d'euros considérant que
cette croissance est là et perdu si je
puis dire
cette économie là est perdu est-ce que
ça appellerait pas plus un renforcement
dieu des mesures de soutien et de
relance
enfin je constate que dans le rapport
appuyé comme dans vos simulations vous
partez de prévision de remontée des taux
extrêmement pessimiste ce qui vient en
pèse sur les économies éventuellement
nécessaires et puis je reprendrai un
vieux laïcs motive ça ne vous surprendra
pas monsieur le ministre mais je trouve
dommage qu avant de parler de
diminutions de dépenses publiques
on ne se pose pas la question de savoir
s'il ne faut pas retenir à l'impôt déjà
prélevé et j'ai toujours en travers vous
le savez les 10 milliards d'impôts de
production perdue je considère qu'on
avoir une vision sur les impôts de
production on peut se dire qu'il ya une
question mais je trouve pour le moins
malheureux voire maladroit de mettre en
oeuvre cette réforme
l'année où nous avons 9 % de baisse du
pib' voilà monsieur le ministre vous
avez voyez une bonne demi heure pour
répondre à tout le monde
merci monsieur le président je vais
essayer de ne pas vous infliger une
vraie temps une demi-heure montré que je
vais aussi essayer d'être aussi précis
que possible dans les réponses que je
peux apporter d'abord pour dire aux
sénateurs afin que nous avons évidemment
veiller à articuler ce que nous
présentons dans le paix stable avec ce
que nous présenterons dans le pnr r
c'est une logique et une heureuse
logique d'ailleurs même si le pnr a
vocation à peut-être avancer sur la
documentation des réformes que nous
prévoyons de mettre en oeuvre et auquel
nous nous engagerons vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens afin de d'obtenir
à la fois sa validation mais surtout
puisque c'est l'objectif
le déblocage des 40 milliards d'euros
ces 40 milliards sont intégrés dans la
trajectoire financière proposée par le p
stable à hauteur de 17 milliards 3 pour
2021 est de 22,7 milliards pour après
c'est à dire à partir de 2022
sachant qu' il y aura certainement des
restes à payer sur 2023
mais notre objectif est de concentrer
sur le début de la période de bénéfices
du pnr r comme notre objectif est de
concentrer les dépenses du plan de
relance sur le début de la période entre
21 et et 22e minute sur les échéances de
paiement aucun j'allais y venir mais les
échéances de paiement et notamment de
prépaiement si je puis dire aide avance
prévu pour le mois de juillet sont
toujours notre objectif nous souhaitons
avec bono maire que l'adoption du pnr et
son cadre communautaire puisse aller
plus rapidement chez nos partenaires
nous avons été les premiers à l'adopter
nous savons qu'il y a d'autre part le
mans qui doivent le faire assez
rapidement
il ya aussi des pays dans lesquels
l'adoption a donné lieu à la saisie de
telle ou telle cour suprême
je pense notamment à l'allemagne et nous
attendons le dénouement de tout cela
avec de l'impatience pour ce qui
concerne la question des indicateurs
sur la scène européenne je ne reviens
pas sur les déclarations qui ont été
celles du président de la république que
vous avez évoquées et sur les
difficultés qu'il peut y avoir
aujourd'hui dans une période pour
laquelle les clauses des traités sont
suspendus pour ce qui concerne ces
indicateurs à l'est considérés comme
pertinents
nous nous considérons notamment que
l'objectif d'une dette publique limitée
à 60% du pib et certainement l'objectif
le plus obsolète aujourd'hui dans la
mesure où personne ne le respecte et
surtout dans le mesure où nous sommes
dans une situation qui fait que entre
certains pays de la même union
économique qui peut y allant jusqu'à 100
points de différence pour le poids de la
dette
certains états atteignant 160 % alors
que d'autres sont légèrement au-dessus
de 60%
la france et le gouvernement français ne
considèrent pas ce débat sur les
indicateurs comme un débat prioritaire
pour nous en terme d'ordre du jour de
notre propre travail gouvernemental
nous savons que la commission est en
particulier le commissaire john dino
nous aurons dans la commission que le
commissaire l'occasion certainement
d'ici la fin de l'année 2021 de faire un
certain nombre de propositions en
matière de révision de réforme de
travail autour des indicateurs et nous
nous positionnerons en termes de
propositions ou de contre-propositions
sur la base de ces projets qui seront un
défendue par le commissaire aux affaires
monétaires et économiques
nous sommes convaincus qu'un certain
nombre de critères gagneront à être vu
mais la france comme tous les autres
états membres gagnent à un débat qui
sont un débat organisé autour des
propositions de la commission plutôt
qu'autour des propositions portées par
tel ou tel c'est ce qui va nous guider
dans les prochains mois et en terme
d'ordre du jour pour notre travail
gouvernemental
nous considérons que la priorité doit
être donnée à la sortie de crise et à la
relance avant d'aller sur ce type de
proposition pour répondre aux sénateurs
de la et concernant les prêts garantis
par l'état
aujourd'hui le système bancaire français
a octroyé 135 milliards d'euros de prêts
garantis par l'état garantit à 90%
nous sommes toujours sur les mêmes
hypothèses en termes de défaillance et
donc de sinistralité
c'est à dire une hypothèse un peu
inférieur à 5% vous pouvez trouver
monsieur le sénateur
dans le programme de stabilité et dans
la partie du programme de stabilité
consacré ce qui est nommé les
contingences les premières provisions
qui sont faites en 2021 pour faire face
à d'éventuelles défaillances
d'entreprises qui auraient souscrit des
pros des prêts garantis par l'état
nous les enfants inscrits pour 2,2
milliards d'euros et vous trouverez mes
collaborateurs m'ont indiqué que c'est à
la page 65 la chronique possible de ces
défaillances et vous trouverez aussi à
la page 25
d'autres chroniques sur d'éventuelles
défaillances que l'état serait amené à
prendre en charge au titre des
contingences et des garanties qu'il a
accordé puisque avant la crise co-lead
l'état avait garanti d'ores et déjà
garanti plus de 200 milliards d'euros de
prêts souscrits par d'autres qui peuvent
amener à prévoir en termes de provisions
ces contingences compte pour ce qui
concerne la sincérité des lois de
finances rectificative et vous avez
évoqué ce qui peut être vu comme des
critiques de la cour des comptes quant
aux cantalous quant au volume des
crédits que nous avons proposé au
parlement d'inscrire à l'occasion des
lois de finances rectificative je leur
ai d'abord rappelé que chacune des lois
finances rectificative que nous avons
déposés a été évidemment présenté au
conseil des finances publiques qui a
toujours considéré dans l'hypothèse
comme cohérente réaliste et prudente et
et je tiens à ces trois adjectifs qui
ont été systématiques
je tiens aussi à rappeler qu'à chaque
fois que nous avons présentées en
particulier pour la dernière d'entre
elles au mois de novembre nous avions
indiqué ça avait donné lieu à un débat
dans cette salle que notre hypothèse
économique et donc budgétaire sans que
ce soit une hypothèse sanitaire était un
confinement qui pouvaient durer non
seulement au mois de novembre mais aussi
au mois de décembre nous avions évoqué
le fait que nous prévoyons où nous
craignons une perte d'activité de 20
points par mois de confinement
il se trouve que la perte d'activité au
mois de novembre a été limité à 11
points
c'est certainement un effet sous-estimé
de notre part du maintien des écoles et
des établissements scolaires ouverts en
termes de maintien d'activités et c'est
aussi dû au fait que le temps passant
les entreprises ont aussi adapter leur
mode d'organisation leur mode de
production à des périodes de confinement
et de restrictions pour le mois de
décembre la perte d'activité a été moins
importante car il n'y avait plus de
confinement mais un système du
couvre-feu et de restrictions dans
certains secteurs
et la perte d'activité a été limité si
je puis dire à hauteur de 7 à 8%
le fait de constater une perte
d'activité de 11 puis de 7% en lieu et
place d'une perte d'activité de deux
fois 20 % explique grandement la
situation en fin d'exercice sur une
sous-consommation des mesures d'urgence
par ailleurs le maintien de l'activité
s'est aussi traduit par des recettes
fiscales plus importantes que ce que
nous avions imaginé
c'est ainsi que à la fin de l'exercice
la différence que l'on a constaté en
termes de moindre dégradation du déficit
public du déficit de l'état pardon à
hauteur de 45 milliards d'euros
s'explique pour 29 milliards par la non
consommation de mesures d'urgence du
fait d'une activité maintenue à un
niveau plus élevé et par 7 milliards
pour des recettes fiscales plus
importantes que prévu en tout cas moins
dégradée toujours lié à une activité
plus soutenue que ce que nous avions
anticipé
je pense notamment au repos d'hier et
tva à la fin de la période
et donc j'ai assumé nous assumons
totalement le fait d'avoir était
peut-être trop prudent et de devoir
reporter des crédits sur l'exercice 2010
21 car je préfère être devant vous dans
la situation qui est celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui c'est à dire une
situation qui nous a amené à reporter
sur 2021 une trentaine de milliards
d'euros qui n'avait pas été consommée en
plutôt que d'avoir pris le risque
précédemment d'être dans une situation
où la situation sanitaire aurait été
plus dégradés que prévu et où nous
aurions été surpris ou empêcher pour des
problèmes de trésorerie dans le
versement du fonds de solidarité ou dans
le paiement de l'activité partielle et
j'ai en tête un échange avec un de vos
collègues sénateurs de paris qui
considéraient que le fait d'avoir
inscrit des crédits pour tenir deux mois
de confinement avec une perte d'activité
de 20 points signifier que le
gouvernement avait anticipé un
confinement de deux mois je lui avais
répondu que ce n'était pas une hypothèse
sanitaire mais qu' étant au mois de
novembre et n'ayant plus le temps
matériel de vous proposer un cinquième
plfr il était de bonne politique à nos
yeux de prévoir l'hypothèse la plus
dégradée pour pouvoir y faire face au
cas où elle aurait été constaté pour ce
qui concerne les questions évoquées par
madame sophie calle po lyon d'abord pour
vous dire madame comme les 3% auquel
nous aspirons de revenir en 2027
je disais à mon propos liminaire ne sont
pas liés à une forme
d'attachement un indicateur européen
autour des 3% par contre nous constatons
qu avec les hypothèses d'inflation les
hypothèses de croissance qui sont
retenus le fait de revenir très
légèrement au-dessus de 3% pourrait tout
à fait précis autour de 3,1 ou 3 2% nous
permet d'entrer dans une période est
d'être dans une situation de finances
publiques qui nous amène à voir le poids
de la dette par eau par rapport au pic
baissé c'est une forme peut-être de
hasard drôle ou malheureux de l'histoire
que de constater qu'aujourd'hui ce 3% et
le point d'inflexion et d'ailleurs c'est
d'autant plus un hasard étonnant que
lorsque les 3% et dépenser comme un
indicateur européen pertinent il ya
maintenant quelques décennies c'était
exactement avec le même objectif mais
avec des hypothèses de croissance et
d'inflation qui n'était pas le même que
celle que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
donc ça n'est pas cet attachement où
cette forme de fétichisme 3% mais bien
la volonté de revenir à une situation
qui nous permettent de maîtriser le
poids de la dette publique et de le
faire baisser
je ne reprends pas ce que je me dis tout
à l'heure à monsieur le rapporteur
général sur la programmation des
investissements puisque je dis que le
paceman n'était pas un document fait
pour cela par contre je souscris à une
partie de votre propos d'abord en
considérant que le passé doit nous
instruire et qu'il ne faut pas vouloir
revenir à une forme d' équilibre trop
rapidement au risque d'étouffer la
croissance de la même manière nous
considérons que les augmentations
d'impôts qui ont suivi la crise de 2010
tant pour les ménages dans un premier
temps pour les entreprises anciens dans
un seconde n'ont pas permis la
croissance ce qui nous amène à
privilégier la piste qui est la nôtre
l'hypothèse qu'il a notre d'un maintien
de notre trajectoire de diminution des
prélèvements tant pour les ménages que
pour les entreprises et in fine et à la
fin du quinquennat d'être à 50 milliards
d'euros de baisse des prélèvements
obligatoires de baisse des impôts
répartis pour moitié au profit des
ménages et pour moitié aux profits des
entreprises mais nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir
un mot sur le sénateur gainey avait voté
à évoquer la question des collectivités
locales je ne vais pas évoqué dans mon
propos sur l'aggravation du déficit
public vous l'avez très certainement
noté le déficit de la sécurité sociale
est passée d'un peu moins de 6 milliards
à 38,6 milliards d'euros celui de l'état
de 93 à 178
les collectivités locales ont vu leurs
recettes réelles de fonctionnement
diminué de 1,4 pour cent tout ça de
manière très macroéconomique il ya de
l'hétérogénéité et leurs dépenses être
maîtrisé à hauteur de +0 2%
là aussi c'est une moyenne macro
économique dans la mesure où les
collectivités locales avait affiché un
excédent de 1,2 milliards en 2019
cette légère et fait six ans que nous
constatons 2020 se traduit non pas par
une situation de déficit du compte des
collectivités locales est paru un retour
à l'équilibré c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans la note de l'insee
concernant le déficit public publie il
ya quelques semaines le compte des
collectivités locales apparaît à l'
équilibre
même si le compte des apu de manière
plus générale est légèrement déficitaire
puisque les apu l'intègre d'autres
opérateurs et d'autres acteurs de la
dépense que les seules collectivités
locales j'ai la conviction elle est
personnelle et permettez-moi de vous la
livrer que le contrat de cahors est un
bon outil de maîtrise de l'évolution des
dépenses j'avais eu l'occasion de le
dire devant votre assemblée et j'ai
aussi la conviction que nous gagnerons à
reprendre ce type d'outils très
certainement en l'aménageant peut-être
en élargissant son champ et en trouvant
des modalités différentes du précédent
ce que je sais par contre c'est que un
tel contrat n'est possible que dans le
cadre de l'examen d'une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle des finances
publiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement dit son attachement en
termes de réforme de la gouvernance des
finances publiques à une norme de
dépense dans d'évolution la dépenses
pluriannuels tous secteurs de la
dépenses confondues en le déclinant sur
chacun des secteurs
les administrations de sécurité sociale
l'état et les collectivités et que c'est
à l'occasion d'une prochaine loi de
programmation nous pourrons ensemble
arrêté les modalités de cet outil qui
pourrait permettre de tenir
l'évolution de la dépense des
collectivités locales en gardant en tête
que si nous l'avons suspendue dans son
application 2020 du fait de la crise les
années 2018 et 2019 avait démontré que
cet outil était efficace dans la mesure
où l'objectif d'évolution inférieur à
1,2 pour cent avait été très largement
tenues et si j'osais l'objectif de 0,7
pour cent l'été l'été aussi
sur la question évoquée par monsieur le
sénateur ferro de la crédibilité
je ne voudrais pas la même réponse que
mon prédécesseur vous l'avez fait vous
même mais je vais simplement souligné
qu' il est peut-être une différence est
que ce qu'il a fait me permettent de le
souligner c'est que sur les trois
premières années du quinquennat les
engagements ont été tenus ils les
prélèvements aux médiateurs ont baissé
le poids de la dépense publique dans le
pib a baissé et nous allons tenir
l'objectif où cet indicateur des 3%
trois années consécutives et que ce que
nous avons fait là nous pouvons le
refaire avec il est vrai un effort
peut-être un peu plus conséquents
puisque nous étions sur le quinquennat
2012-2017 1% sur les trois premières
années du quinquennat 2017 2022
un peu moins de 3 % et + être encore
plus précis sur 2018-2019 nous étions
très 0,5 et 0,6 pour cent avec une année
2010 8 qui était assez particulière nous
l'avons tous en tête
je ne crois pas par contre que le renvoi
au déficit structurel puisse trouver
beaucoup d'acuité dans la période que
nous connaissons le traitement et par la
commission comme par l'insee des
dépenses d'urgence et de relance avec
pour les dépenses d'urgence la
caractérisation en mauvais français de
one of rend extrêmement difficile et
explique les variations vous pouvez voir
dans la chronique sur déficit structurel
et je crains que nous ayons quelques
années avant que ce déficit structurel
puisse redevenir un indicateur tout à
fait pertinent est tout à fait lisible
en tout cas en première analyse sur des
questions de prélèvements obligatoires
et moment politique
vous l'avez aussi sous entendu nous ne
partons pas tout à fait du même niveau
en matière de prélèvements obligatoires
de manière générale nous sommes à 45
quand les etats unis sont à moins de 25
et donc si la convergence tant mieux si
au delà des convergences décidé par
chaque état il y a un travail tel que
annoncé par l'administration d'haydn au
sein de l' ocde pour un taux d'impôt sur
les sociétés minimale tant mieux nous
les soutiendrons même si nous gardons de
la prudence puisque nous savons qu'il
peut y avoir une différence entre l'
annonce à laquelle nous souscrivons de
l'administration d'haydn et ce qui
sortira du parlement américain et c'est
bien normal
les débats se dérouleront
aussi pour ce qui concerne les questions
évoquées par michel canevet notamment
sur les questions de dépenses de
personnel je suis en mesure de dire
monsieur le sénateur que notre objectif
en 2022 comme en 2021 c'est la stabilité
du schéma d'emplois ce qui est une forme
de souplesse si l'on peut dire dans la
mesure où notre programmation
pluriannuelle initiales prévoyaient
plutôt un schéma d'enfin négatif mais
nous sommes sur une volonté de stabilité
et ce d'autant plus que l'année 2020
s'est traduite par une augmentation du
nombre d'emplois de l'état pour
certaines mesures par fruit de décisions
politiques avant la crise qu vide je
pense au maintien des écoles en zone
rurale pour 1500 et épais au plan bts
pour 450
par contre la crise qu vide a aussi
amené à des créations d'emplois liés à
cette crise à hauteur de plus de 2300
pour pôle emploi de quelques centaines
pour l'afpa de 450 pour le ministère de
la santé
autant de décisions qui ont dû être
prises pour faire face à la crise ce qui
nous incite à observer avec encore plus
d'attention la stabilité en 2021 et en
2022 sûr pour ce qui concerne les
contrats des conseils départementaux
pardon vous avez raison sur leurs
caractéristiques et je compte beaucoup
sur le travail que nous menons
actuellement d'expérimentation telle que
prévue par les lois de finances en
matière de recentralisation du
financement du rsa pour voir sur
plusieurs départements et des
caractéristiques différentes ce qui peut
en être tirées pardonnez moi
l'expression retenue pour avancer en la
matière pour répondre aux sénateurs
bachir nous avons effectivement même pas
intégrer une chronique d'évolution du
taux de chômage
considérant qu'un certitude était trop
forte par contre vous avez très
certainement noté en page 25 que les
prestations chômage étaient orientés à
la hausse sur 2021 et 2022 et nous
considérons que l'objectif que nous
avons de retour n'a à une activité égale
à celle que nous connaissions en 2019 au
cours de l'année 2022 permettra la
stabilisation tout comme la mise en
oeuvre des mesures d'activité partielle
sur la question du 0,7 pour cent j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre précédemment et
pour ce qui concerne les hypothèses
d'inflation comme les autres hypothèses
retenues en sous jacent
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que nous
étions sûrs
hypothèse conventionnel qui sont
communément admise pour cet exercice
pour les questions posées par madame
bavarde sur les collectivités
je ne crois pas véritablement à damas
sénatrice que les collectivités sont les
seuls à payer dans la mesure où ce sont
aujourd'hui des trois secteurs de
l'action publique les plus préservés des
effets de la crise et que sans revenir
sur mes réponses aux sénateurs gainey je
considère que petit personnel je répète
que les la contractualisation tel que
prévu avec les contrats de cahors est
une bonne méthode pour à la fois
permettre une augmentation des dépenses
quand c'est nécessaire et est voulue
mais aussi l'encadré éviter qu'il y ait
de tels dérapages
je n'ai pas le chiffre sur le coût pour
les employeurs de la za il faudrait que
nous puissions regarder le coût horaire
de chacun des agents placés en nasa et
par multiplication est arrivé je vais
voir si nous en disposons je n'ai jamais
connu jusqu alors donc je vais voir si
je les si j'allais je le partagerai bien
évidemment avec vous deux derniers
points pour répondre aux sénateurs
delcros d'abord pour dire que nous nous
nous allons renouveler la baisse des
impôts de production en étant précis ils
ont baissé de 10 milliards d'euros pour
les entreprises financées par le plan de
relance
ils ne baisseront pas de 10 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires c'est le
renouvellement de cette baisse en 2021
2022 qui sera ainsi à financer
sinon le président reynal m'en voudrais
deux fois plus qu'il ne m'en vais déjà
et je ne voudrais pas prendre ce risque
là par contre je vous confirme que notre
objectif en termes d'impôts sur les
sociétés reste le même avec la
trajectoire que nous avons fixés en
forme
vous avez évoqué les questions de
gouvernance et de capacités attendre les
0 7%
j'ai évoqué les projets des propositions
de loi organique qui que nous regardons
avec beaucoup d'intérêt notamment celle
de laurent saint martin et d'eric woerth
qui prévoit la fixation d'une norme de
dépense curé annuel toutes
administrations publiques confondues qui
prévoit aussi de renforcer les
prérogatives du haut conseil des
finances publiques et qui prévoit aussi
de peut-être demander ou prévoir que le
parlement et le gouvernement passent
plus de temps sur la question de la
dette et ses conséquences sur les
finances publiques et sur les marges
dont nous disposons et si nous n'avons
que peu évoqué les questions de
gouvernance à d'exception
de celles concernant les collectivités
je pense véritablement que ça peut être
là un bon levier est un bon outil à
condition qu'ils soient le plus
consensuel possible pour être le plus
partagé possible
merci merci monsieur le ministre
malgré comment dire le fait qu'on eut
effectivement les documents tardivement
je pense qu'on a pu quand même avoir un
premier échange qui était utile pour
tous en tout cas je vous renvoie mes
chers collègues je voulais déjà dit mais
je le redis à un échange en commission
deuxième échange en commission le
mercredi 5 mai à partir de l'analyse que
nous enverra durant donc la suspension
le rapporteur général sur ce programme
de stabilité
[Musique]